all right okay hello everyone we are
continuing the large collection of
design reviews for version 14. today
it's one about visualization
so
so we have a family of pairwise plotting
functions they will put up
an N by n Grid or panels
and they allow you to
plot High dimensional data sets and get
insights of various kinds so the first
three
allow you for instance to detect
correlations you know so I mean if I'd
say things like pairwise
list plot of random real
ten comma let's say
uh
something like 10 10 10.
no it's more like a hundred comma 10.
yes
oh so it doesn't deal with whatever why
is it hanging it's probably doing
multi-data sets
um
but it's not going to be
okay
well so explain this to me so I mean
this the scales look pretty funky down
here
so I mean the data you gave is the least
interesting of all possible dates
but sure right okay so so do 20 comma
10.
it's very very slow what's going on here
what's coming 100 and you know needs
after you need some optimization okay it
sure does yes
um
so you have 20 points that are 10
dimensional
right
and and so males look like I mean
look at this stuff here
what the hell is going on there
some of them are 0.0 some of them are
zero two four what the hell's going on
here
well it probably depends a little bit on
what values happen to me in each
position well this looks terrible
well I don't think it's a good idea to
have that the scales change
well I mean the alternative is I mean
you end up with
you know lots of stuff colliding
okay let me understand what this picture
is of
so
in panel IJ row I column J
you project down to the coordinates I
comma J and it's kind of squared things
here yep right yes but this is this is
the identity why isn't it on the leading
diagonal why is it on the backwards
diagonal
it is on the leading diagonal
no what do you mean it's going backwards
here the leading diagonal will be down
here
but the thing correlated with itself
yeah so you know if you if you plot X if
you plot X comma X for different values
of X it's going to be a diagonal okay
fine yep
foreign
okay
all right
so let me plot something more
interesting
what um I mean if I advice say
random real go to the documentation for
pairwise list plot it has
oh my gosh sorry
so that just really needs optimization
and this really doesn't look good I mean
I think you need a way to lock these
scales to be the same
but they aren't necessarily the same no
I understand but they could be made the
same I mean you could make them
you know we can make them all plot range
you know we could throw all the points
in and say what's the plot range
automatic version of all those points
because that way this thing would be
meaningful otherwise this thing is
meaningless
no that would not be meaningful
I mean look at the examples in the
documentation for pairwise list but I
don't understand
Stephen you are generating points with
10 Dimensions all coming from the same
distribution I know you know in reality
this is going to be like your height and
your weight and well sometimes yeah
there's no you know sometimes it will be
uniform right column is going to be
sometimes it will be uniform sometimes
it will not be sometimes the dimensions
will all be you know meaning the same
kind of thing and sometimes they won't
be that's what I'm suggesting this is a
case where they do happen to mean the
same thing and why you should lock the
the scales together
even though it might be the default
should not be to do that but you should
have a way to do it right I mean the way
to do that would be with plot range
okay so if I say here
plot range Arrow
automatic
what will that do well that will that
throw everything that is probably what
it's doing right now okay so if you said
plot range goes to minus 20 minus 20 you
know minus 2020 minus 20 20.
or whatever
-10 I guess we're getting down to 20 in
some cases
that will do that won't it should I
don't remember if that's 0 to 20 or
yeah okay minus 20 to 20.
okay that's more I'm much more
informative than the previous one
but that's a very special case well it's
not that special a case it's a case
where the data happens to be you have a
high dimensional function
not something where every piece of data
and every Dimension comes from a
different thing
they're two cases right this is more of
the kind of pure case the other case is
more of the applied case I don't think
this case is so totally irrelevant
I certainly would have had applications
for this over the years
okay we can come up with a Syntax for
you know plot range to sync everything
I think full does it now
does it again
uh pluck Ranger full
I really doubt that that seems very good
seems totally crazy
I mean that is what I was going to
suggest for that
yo
okay really that this is the right thing
well I'm surprised by that it doesn't
seem quite right to me
um
okay I mean I don't think full normally
has you know no a meaning for this case
I mean for this type of you know list
plot
okay so can I take a data set and plot
it this way
I think so it should I I don't I'm not
100 confident that's been hooked up but
it's certainly you know
on the list if it isn't
that's going to be really boring
well
let's just see it
is this new this color
which the is that a pinkish color yeah
okay that was boring
um okay how do we see someone which is
more multimensional with numbers rather
than categorical data
uh go ahead and scroll down to the basic
examples in the docs
okay I was gonna ask about Mr Fish Es
are Mr fish's irises
yes I mean they are a classic example
for this type of plot
okay now here
each panel is chosen with its scales
different right correct now is there any
way that I can see where which data
point can corresponds to which data
points in another panel no yeah not at
the moment that's something we would
like to have as part of the interaction
um I'm not sure we're going to make it
for this release because it might that
requires some underlying data structures
to back
but yeah you're right Stephen that that
is a key key interaction points to know
which ones are you know connected
and often you do you select a group of
points
and a group of points light up in all
the other panels
let's see
another rectangular pixels are kind of
unpleasant
yeah I think we should try to get them
square if we can
I think so
this will look nicer
yeah
looks pretty good
I mean hard to know what now why isn't
it labeled with you know petals and
stuff you know and whatever they are
because that's not in that data set
um I see normal is there what's the
option setting for that or is there an
example
um
comment and chat
okay
all right now let's try pewai smooth
histogram
that let's watch something exciting
happen here
so but it's exciting
that's nice
now for this categorical data can we get
different colors or something for that
I mean at the moment it would be
a manual thing and you wouldn't do it
with the histograms
um what was that oh that was you were
evaluating
um
one day that should work right yeah so
if you did like okay what why is this
gray and this not gray oh is this
different
what what Steven uh right yeah I think
it's very subtle over Zoom yeah it's
very subtle over soon but the intent is
not to bury it out okay
right and so if you did
yeah like
have we had design look at this
not yet other than Tim because I'm I'm
wondering is Tim here
I don't remember if Tim is here so we
have a long actually it would be useful
if Tim joined and we could showcase some
of the designs that we're aiming for
which is baked into some of the themes
fine to be competitive because I mean
here
I I'm wondering whether these should be
lightened these borders I don't know
doesn't look bad right now but I just
wonder we have light in them a little
bit
but I don't know for you
how well is plot team section filled out
normal in the docks
uh
try web
I think it's not obvious to me that we
need the gutters in general
are the gutters really doing anything
for us I I think they just look kind of
you know confusing and the I think they
help on the density cases for sure
I see
um
well it looks like the density still has
a little bit of plot range padding so
maybe they aren't necessary even there
but
well in this case
if we know these are going to be dark we
could have these these lines be white
yeah
I don't know if that will work but at
least 50 correct try
um could you try pairwise list plot with
Wham
I want to know the following thing how
do I change the um the color of the of
the you know crisscross lines
what's the option to do that
uh
past be an appearance option with a
Association of things or something
see so that would not be grid lines
possibly we overlooked that one somehow
okay uh try frame style because to White
yeah it should be frame Style with
Proline on hooked up
it worked it's very nice
that's pretty nice it seems to me
we need design involved in this okay
because that looks so so we have Tim has
done a lot of design and we can bring in
the other design too
yeah okay but this looks good to me and
I would I would just go
you know tighten me
you know pick frame colors that are
contrasty by default yeah I suspect if
we say gray level 0.5
don't know fairly reasonable a little
bit late I mean but but
if it's thicker
what would happen
that's absolutely fine
mm-hmm
so there's a way to do this
um
so some of the things that we have had
to work on to fix is that
often these labels
the variable labels basically along
I see
you know and I think we have a good
repertoire of solutions for that
um
well can you show me a gallery of what
of things that happen I mean I also I'm
not convinced that this is the right
default color scheme by the way
looks very um you know
uh Victorian ghost oriented
and like those auras and things you know
you try for
um could you try the list plot instead
of that one I haven't even seen this one
myself
what is that
that's web that's no but yeah
thank you
right I think the background on the
headers is too dark on this one but yeah
it is
I don't know this doesn't look too
terrible to me but there's some way
there's some things a little bit
heavyweight there and stuff well but
that's but I set the frame style so oh
you did okay I didn't see that
that'll help yeah I thought that was
pretty good
okay
all right what else should we look at
here I mean I don't know
my input would be
you know some graphic design work
removing those gutters things like this
probably is Tim coming or not coming or
can we show the design no it's fine
Jeremy please
I'm trying to yeah I'm trying to reach
him and I mean I'm paying him
okay
but what else would you like to
highlight with me and and then we're
also going to look at these univariate
functions
yes you haven't given an example of that
where's the example
um it just opened a page because we
hadn't done the illustrations at the
time I wrote this
we're still to some extent working on
them
so those these two are a little bit
different in that what they do
so the way you go from input data
n-dimensional
is that you look at you compare every
pair
of columns basically
you know to see how their distributions
distribution of values relate to each
other
it's basically what they do
there's the other ones about a
visualization directions okay so there
are still some plots that we don't have
like this um
gosh what is it called the the Sankey
diagram things like that sure that uh
for much simpler kinds of data than
these
we really need those
sure
I mean these things that deal with you
know I have not used radio
whatever it's called plot
what is it called radiation
I haven't used that yet
and which is a bit surprising
um
Andrew on the live stream is commenting
will there be improvements to Graphics
Aesthetics when using the multi-axis
functionality for example things like
grid lines frame label do not work
easily when using multiplexes says
I'm not sure if any of those fixes are
going for 14 but
um
okay
all right but I don't understand this
damn plot so maybe I should just see
what the heck is this so this is
quanta plot a variable a against
variable B
right
I don't by the way I see why you don't
use I think you should use in the basic
example something which does have labels
because I think otherwise people just
don't know that there are possibility of
labels there
that's a good point
I mean since you're hiding the input
data anyway right we can hide it we can
hide the labeled version
I really hate the way that those scales
just look so messy
I guess there's no choice but it just
they seem awfully
those are one of the areas you know that
pose difficulties you know you know not
just for us but you know for everyone
who creates these types of yeah plots of
you know it's interesting to see you
know sort of how different you know
people do it and
where it breaks down and
yeah okay
um well this question whether we have
gutters between the things or whether
they are coincident is something we
should figure out how would I set an
option to make those things go into it
zero
I don't know
I mean the points there are so you know
that you can barely see the points that
you're mostly seeing the you know the
the crisscross in the window you're not
seeing anything in the view
I know why maybe the points are too
small I I think the points are too small
um I think it was also another style of
points
yep it's coming from the age form of the
point so if you set a plot theme you'll
probably be able to see I don't want to
say about them I want to set plot Style
sure
and how do I set that
yeah you can just set it to any color
and no I'm not talking about the color
I'm talking about I'm talking about
making these points bigger
um absolute Point size of three
should be plenty big
it's not as big as I was expecting
well now when I expand this it gets
bigger which is very odd because it's an
absolute Point size
yes
I'm going to try an absolute Point size
of six to see if it's even doing
anything
oh there we go
yeah so he's not doing anything okay so
yeah
just
was doing something last week I thought
or maybe it was just colored somehow
um
okay so this is a quantile plot
you've got
one thing against the other
and you're sorting
I don't understand normally in a
quantile plot
so this is the bottom left corner is
going to be the minimum and the minimum
yeah okay
and then to maximum yep a maximum
okay all right I understand what this is
what is that
that's a unit framework regression
this is Irish data have units on it
um
well maybe it does probably not
oh and why does it say this
let's try
I mean so the fact that the probability
and quantile plots generally share a lot
of code
okay so something went wrong
yes something went weird
foreign
should we look at I mean you were going
to show me a bunch of aesthetic choices
yeah so if if maybe Tim can share or you
can send you the notebook would be great
no but why don't you send it to me
please
Tim
here just I don't I have here let me put
one together real quick of what I did
before where's the one that you have for
General multi-panel stuff
okay yeah with all the components
well who's doing the so one scheme that
we learned by the way Stephen which may
be applicable in a bunch of other cases
of labeling
is is to have the
um panel labels fade out when they get
too long that's interesting idea if you
resize one of those plots and make it
you know like half width
I think they're going to resize with the
oh that's boring
well that is a bug that you've got to
fix okay that's the same bug that I was
reporting to you on uh Graphics grid
about the fonts being broken off right
you understand that bugs yep I I
understand that bug
um
okay so at that size you should do
something about these right you should
probably either remove those or
something I mean the only reason that
they that the fonts look okay is because
they weren't out of range
so there's more to do here
you should make the scales change
in size as well I would assume
are these changing inside I don't think
they're changing in size I think there's
a measurement that's in the wrong
coordinate system in there
um
it normal is header display function
fade working
yep that should work
so what should I do here
um you can do column labels
um pick one of the ones that's doing the
data set yep and then
header display function goes to the
string fade
ah only picked
where's that pinking
well
uh okay they're not working but but I
like the idea of fading light so it
turned out that that is in fact the same
scheme we didn't know about that but
then we learned it's the same scheme
that's web browsers use and Etc and for
long URLs in the URL field hmm
as opposed to dot dot dot yeah it's an
interesting idea
okay
okay all right what else should we see
here
I think that's about it there's maybe a
question that you have an opinion about
which is that we co-opted a bunch of
options
that are basically for
for individual plots and you're using
them for the whole Gaggle plots right
well that's true but we also are using
like a lot of data set options and
you know like the spacings and like
header display function
is a data set option originally
I don't think that's terrible
okay
I think we should leave them
experimental until we have a little bit
more of these in
you know
won't you uh widen the notebook a little
bit
I'm not sure there we go
uh yeah reading across yeah all of that
specified plot layout
right and and some of the stuff in Tim's
notebook is for functionality that's not
in this not for this version
that is
related
um yeah so the aspect ratio
could be the individual panel aspect
ratio it could be the aspect ratio of
the whole thing
right and we're doing the individual
panel
okay but for some other things you're
not
correct
image size you're presumably doing the
whole thing yep
oh boy oh boy
oh boy
that's kind of annoying
it is but I think for most of the
options at least there's
a pretty obvious you know which way you
want it to behave
I think that's Patricia is not so
obvious if you have a collection well I
mean well okay so you know aspect ratio
for a normal plot
is not you know the ratio for the image
size
yeah I understand that
so
what is this
this is for missing data no that's not
for this that's not for the pairwise
stuff no it's not for the pairwise yeah
this uh all these were done before we
even started on pairwise it was just
something to get us started
but one of the things for instance you
know so we rotate labels and so now you
don't really want to your head at
two different directions right pocket
left and then it right
so we consistently rotate there's like
if you're going to your head at
least it's only one direction
you're cocking for this one because
you're reading it like you would
ordinarily read it we'll put the label
on the right what about the x-axis
e-u-u-s connect Canada and the right
Edge
well that's a single recocking so to
speak exactly we explicitly made it it's
only one
we could have flipped it so if there
wasn't like an ostrich reading these it
was just on emu or something it will
just never mind exactly
that reminds me of a comic I saw
it's a doctor I'm sorry it's a dog
teaching out of dogs and all the dogs
are cocking their heads left and right
like from all the cockingham heads I
think I'm going to re-explain this topic
huh
okay
so what's this
how did you get the is that getable in
in the current setup or is that
something this whole everything in here
is faked so
just to get an idea across
okay how are we doing this label inside
labeler you know how is that working
so at the moment I mean so this is you
know for a thing for where individual
panels make sense to be labeled which is
not the pairwise case
right in pairwise you want to label the
rows you want to label the columns right
okay but um I could in principle do this
with Place somehow
and pairwise now
I mean
I mean everybody
so I'm just it should give a message
can I say that again
if you try to use placed for a plot
label inside penwise it shouldn't just
silently fail it should give a message
okay
and that's the general principle for
these kinds of you know if you don't
recognize some primitive give a message
don't just silently fail
that should be true across lots of
graphics
am I making sense
I think graphics does that it even pinks
it
no it doesn't do it in many cases I just
it just ignores it in many cases I've
tried to get different effects you know
plot Legends in the right place blah
blah blah it just does nothing right it
just does nothing
and that's wrong okay so you want more
messages out of the vision plotting
functions I do I in other words if you
can't figure out what to do give a
message don't just silently fail
I mean there are cases where
yeah sure
I mean I think for the most part we can
do that
um
you know if you're I mean if you specify
something that you know involves dynamic
you know we can't inspect that
fun but that's
that's a different thing right A lot of
these are individual labeling which we
don't have right now but the pairwise
functions right yes correct
um but the general you know appearance
of what it looks like at the top and
what it looks like on the right
is applicable
yeah
any ideas for what to do with these
I have to tell you
if you ran some kind of color or
something behind those things I think it
would look better but just these round
little bits and leftover like little
pieces of of um
sort of confetti or something
you know are you talking about the ticks
I'm talking about the text yeah I'm
talking about these texts if you were to
for example run a background color
behind all of these or something or some
way
or to tick labels
yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean do you want
it to match the stuff that the labels
that are on the top and right I don't
know
I mean I I think I think I think that
will help make it more integrated
uh I think what happened with too much
emphasis on the tick labels no we don't
because you want them on the heads
can we you know right now they're just
kind of secondary can we find Jeremy
somebody looked for him when I asked
before yeah
so he's findable he's not findable
I'm I'm reaching I'm trying to look him
and
but we also talked about that 10 minutes
ago but
okay but we're not gonna find him okay
so I'm telling you you should talk to
him about I'm telling you something that
involves a light color Behind These or
something like that will help make them
seem more integrated
am I making sense
unless like random play things at
different places
right
and the collisions are pretty ugly
I mean it's very unclear what those two
labels do for us
I'm making sense well I think that we
have another shot when we go interactive
let's say that you get a drop line
both to the to the X and Y then you can
then you can give what the value is yeah
you can light it up with a value then
see that might be in the end the more
useful not sure yet I don't think this
is useful here I mean when you have
a large number well I think that is sort
of a panel you know I think that there's
same thing that we're highlighting
there's sort of the static versions for
a for a for a static publication like
PDF and there's a dynamic version
uh and and sometimes when you publish it
you have to have something there no I I
understand that but I think it's going
to be hard for people I mean that is
just ugly what you have there right now
yeah it is right so I I claim if they
were all equal bins which can happen
from time to time then you could label
the first one and be happy
another thing that's a bit odd which is
which comes out here is that sometimes
it is time to do integers and sometimes
decimals
yeah well that's because sometimes it
has only answers
is a little bit different and so it's
switching between I see so you're saying
you're saying wait a minute so if it's
only going to show integers there's no
reason to have the decibels
all right it's going to show a decimal
then
I see what you mean Roger that is an
interesting observation I wonder why
so drag that plot bigger
so we see more of the ticks
so that's the two four six eight there
in the bottom right and the others are
2.5S
yeah that's that's something that we're
working on the next object side of
things so no Nation
okay but even at this scale these ticks
are really ugly
mm-hmm
yeah they kind of are
so I think header display function
automatic is hooked up to do the fading
if you want to try that but
what's it called now
the header display function automatic
um which you want to do with one with
the labels
well this is how to I mean the headers
or this or the um axes
no this is a header header display
function is not doing anything with the
text is it normal no it's not no okay I
mean I know men was experimenting with
okay I don't know what that is that's
wrong that's an interesting case
um
no that's wrong okay why is this taking
forever to resize
why is it taking forever forever forever
to resize
my hand's been off the mouse for ages
where it just means seconds
yeah I mean it's been off the mouse yeah
and I know what you mean why is it
taking so long to resize
I'm not sure I don't think we're doing
anything so
okay we'll look into it Bugsy something
that came up here
well you've got something going wrong
well take a look at it yeah because it's
not super happy
all right is there anything else we
should cover here no that's it I think I
think that's it
that's nice but I want to see some of
these other diagrams that that are
on simpler to specify data sure
is simpler to specify but we'll yeah I
don't understand why this background is
white in this background is is blue
it's just it's the the the the sparsity
when there's zero in any bin it's it's
left White
okay what is this here isn't that zero
well I mean but those are you know let's
continue continuous function
so there's no you know it's not zero
anywhere
okay whereas with the discrete one you
know parts of it really are zero
I think you know and the zero Parts
aren't sure it's very ugly that the blue
is the Epsilon and white is the zero
yeah I mean we could
well okay so if we look at like density
histogram in general
should that fill in everything
I'm totally confuzzled about what's
Happening Here
this is so that's density histogram but
what about smooth density histogram
hmm
one went you know
positioned itself for the sales
well how important is it to know that
something is empty
I think it's important yeah
but the fact is that that the fact that
the color map here is so different in
those two cases just doesn't seem right
well in the color map is exactly the
same of course but
well but okay but the color but the
effect is different zero is white and
Epsilon is dark blue
just seems wrong
just seems like Epsilon should be close
to White
so often a hybrid I mean the other thing
I was thinking is you know we could make
you know like zero
a shade of gray or something
possibly I just think you need something
consistent here
minor comment I I just don't I think
these I know people often make plots
like this but I think we should rethink
those colors a bit
in view of the other one
right
[Music]
all right I mean because art I mean to
some extent arguably
you know the you know empty squares
should be blue
you know I mean it's I mean they're
white because they aren't having the
color function applied to them
yeah well that's just wrong
if those are zeros in the top one
yeah it just seems wrong but I don't
think that the effect I mean again I
think you need to look at some graphic
design stuff and see what
you know it just it doesn't seem right
that in a sense the um
the most dramatic color is the color
that corresponds to zero
well anyway I should go
um
okay okay good stuff nice okay thank you
thank you see ya